I just got an email letting me know that
Sarah commented on my PO requests she
says that I misspelled canola well I'll
go take a look
canola oil yeah that's not right I'll go
ahead and fix that and I'll commit my
fix now since I want this change to be
visible and github also I'll push
pushing the branch automatically updates
the PO request on github underneath
Sarah's comment about my misspelling you
can see my commits fixing the typos also
if I look at the commits I can see there
are two now and if I look at the files
changed I can see the correct spelling
now I'd like you to follow the same
steps and make a pull request on your
own first create a new branch called
different oil then make a comment on the
different oil branch to use canola oil
instead of vegetable oil like I did if
you want you can make a typo on purpose
but that's optional then push your
different oil branch to your fork on
github and create a pull request make
sure to change the base to the master
branch of your repository and not
Larry's repository if you made a typo
earlier then make another commit to fix
the typo and update the pull request
finally paste the link to your pull
request in this box you can find a link
to your pull request by viewing your
repository on github scrolling over to
the right and looking at the list of
pull requests then click on your pull
request and copy this URL from the URL
bar finally make sure you don't merge
the pull request yet if you do then a
later exercise won't work